welcome back to GameSpot presents the
mix right here at GDC 2015 Alexia
Burbank oh thank you very much for
coming all the way from Russia to show
us your video game today I really really
appreciate it this is the last one we're
showing today but it's also one of the
best looking games we have this is
number nine we've had today at jetpack
squad tell us all about it tell us Perry
game
well it's shoot them up and basically
shoot them up with a focus on speed
interactivity and explosions yeah and
this game heavily uses physics and like
in most shmups you're trying to avoid
the stuff but here the whole game is
built on interaction so basically you
have to like bump up to the stuff from
grab it throw it around and the whole
gameplay is going to be based on that
excellent let's hop right in and you've
got the game loading up already the best
way to show it is by all means - to hop
in and play there is no Bossier so don't
worry it's GDC we're all used to
appreciate you guys showing us early
versions of all these yeah over small
basics you can like jump - around and
shoot enemies the animation is
absolutely gorgeous it's so smooth now
how big is the team that's working on
this there are two or two of you yeah
and you guys are the folks behind
intrusion right intrusion 2 came out in
2012 or something ah yes somewhere
around that time I mean I worked alone
on a children mmm I'm sure - and then
this game working together oh it's a say
this is not the easiest game to play
yeah awkward at the same time there's so
much going on oh wow I'm doing pretty
bad so yeah you've got the sword you can
like cut enemies and reflect the bullets
so it gets very useful when you get like
a barrage of bullets
yeah cuz it's between you were not only
did you like rebound a bullet but you
also like picked up the projectile and
threw it back
so type of attack you can have objects
and throw them around and it's so smooth
I do have you do you do the art as well
for this or is that who you're your
second-in-command is is helping with
yeah I think yeah this is like one of
the more difficult games to talk about
and play at the same time basically the
other guys name is Alex Nick enough he
does the background out the character
art and I'm doing the programming and
animation and they begin to then oh my
god and so what is it like in terms of
progression than are you is this a short
game that you're expecting people to
play over and over again like speed run
style yeah most likely mm-hmm we will
try to make it as a playable as possible
and it's difficult as possible for
seemingly as well and yeah what is the
difficult aggression like is this one of
the more challenging levels this one of
the easier levels what is that octopus
students so now I'm trying to make it
like the average gameplay hmm so before
that they'll be like introduction level
where you hold on all your abilities
like all the controls so now it's just
like core gameplay I like that eyeballs
still looking at you after he's after
he's been defeated oh my god can you
pick up those guys as well I know there
holds to the ground I mean I can pick
this one like this so yeah it seems to
be a lot of variety in terms of the
enemies that you have in this game we're
already a team of two people how long
have you been working on this for about
a year and a half and before that I was
doing the engine I was making the engine
basically I didn't know what project I
will start next so yeah I'm just working
on general stuff what was there
something about working on the the
previous two games that something
specific he wanted to do with with with
Jeff Beck's squad that you didn't do in
the
in that series I mean what I didn't do
an intrusion yeah like in terms of a
like development was there something
like a different type of game you wanted
to make yeah like one thing I wanted to
do intrusion was mainly blue green and
orange that's was like three colors it
was using and here I'm trying to use as
much as possible without it looking ugly
yeah it looks absolutely it looks
fantastic especially considering there's
only two two people working on it it's
the it's the the motion actually the
animation the smoothness of it is what's
so striking about it because the the
graphics themselves are obviously you
can make them as good as you want but
just combining it with everything else
with the the effects as well and
particles and whatnot is there any sort
of story happening in this game is there
any like progression in terms of your
abilities or is it all very much the
same at the start you know we're
planning to make like different
characters so you can collect the
characters and choose them before for
the level so they'll have like special
abilities and the passive effects like
some can have more more speed or like
more lifeforce hmm different weapons
perhaps more yeah different like we get
melee weapons so good they're very
different weapons I like just picking up
stones and throwing you pick up that van
as well it's a big bit too big yeah fair
enough
these ninja dudes there any co-op any
online sort of stuffers it's very much a
single-player like speedrun type of high
scores of you will probably think about
a local co-op multiplayer I mean I'm
guessing you encourage players to
interact with the various enemies as
much as possible yeah because you're
right it's like it's a whole different
type of like most shmups you're just
basically destroying everything in your
path and you stay away from them as
almost the key but you're like
encouraging people to sort of get in
there and [ __ ] about with these things
destroy trees no I got this
I mean I couldn't cut the grass but if
you've been over for GDC before it's a
long way to fly over from Russia and
yeah it's around 20 hours from there
I've been - it's my third time on did
you see oh yeah I mean the Troodon was
on that Jeff mm like of course yeah oh
and what's it like actually coming over
here to is the developments
is there a development community in
Russia that's sort of largely not known
of in North America or do you find when
you come to something at GDC that that's
when you're right meeting people within
your world again well yeah there is a
community but like I live in the small
town so in my town there is like no
community mmm so I mean there are with
specialized conventions like developer
conventions and game conventions in
Moscow and some pictures but I think
oh my god we always near the end of this
level or yeah almost neither is there in
big dirty boss at the end we've to fight
well there is but it's not ready yet
really well just bad SAP before that
happens excellent what platforms is it
going to come out on and do you have any
sort of idea what about well it's made
on unity so it's very the platform I
mean like right now we're planning for
PC Mac and Linux and potentially come up
on consoles if we talk to some people
here this week GDC perhaps about that
that seems to be something that comes up
a lot with that indie developers we have
been here since the boss that isn't
finished yet
oh man yeah it's not finished I can show
some patterns but yeah probably will do
something ugly all right hey listen yeah
they said to demo and we'll ends let's
let's just see what happens Jesus Christ
what's going on in this world that there
are massive robotic is that some sort of
scorpion pig scorpion spider
have you watched my neighbor totoro no
buying ads okay yeah basically they had
like a character that was a cat with 12
legs okay so that's just a cat with it
with a little mice tail I guess is there
people inside of it yeah alright alright
I believe in you
I know this isn't even finished so
perhaps it's not actually possible to
destroy this what's what have you named
it well cat boss mice so what it's
written in in the code at first level I
mean that's the name from Totoro okay I
guess they don't cease and desist us not
yet
let's not say yeah we'll just we'll edit
this part I don't worry of excellence
how many different with this level then
how many levels are in the game of this
sort of like average lengths like well
of this length well we're planning at
least three chapters basically and
laughs of each chapter would be like
slightly bigger than this level
hmm well it's the medium basically
whatever I plan for now yeah I got
destroy the tail he wants got it is that
the is well that move do you think all
the characters have that moved the sort
of its kind of acquired the the circular
shoot and move because of the amount of
enemies that are behind you all the time
yeah that's it
yeah hair balls are awful is this one of
those three level bosses
oh yeah and basically that's the end of
all patterns go continue doing that oh
really
forever yeah I never it doesn't explode
okay
let's cut it there then I appreciate it
at least seeing some of the end boss as
somebody who owns a cat as well much
appreciate it likes you thank you so
much for coming in and as you said this
is coming out on PC Mac Linux or maybe
on consoles do you've any idea when
abouts this will be aired we next year
or sometime this year or yeah we hope
next year but we have no idea how much
to take fingers crossed you still got it
you still got some work to do thank you
so much for coming in and enjoy the rest
you GDC again actually pleasure to have
you here
you